okay so due to the tiny why me wibbly
wobbly nature of tenet
the opening is arguably one of the most
confusing things ever put to film
who is the protagonist working for why
do the swat team members turn on him
what happens to the algorithm and what
the hell is everyone saying
i'm not sure you made it loud enough
well we're gonna be breaking it all down
and answering some of the big questions
to clear up any confusion
if this is your first time here then
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul for the next hill
okay so whilst i normally tend to do
ending explains
because of tennis plot structure and
time manipulation i think it's actually
fitting that this is the first film that
i break down the opening of
throughout the movie we're told that
ignorance is a weapon and at almost
every major plot point in the movie the
protagonist has absolutely no idea
what's going on
this is very much the case with the
audience too and nolan purposely drops
us in at the deep end
so that like the lead we have little to
no idea what's going on
now up top this is happening at the
exact same moment that the mission at
stahls 12 is
and across the timeline a version of
both neil and the protagonists are
storming sator's forces
in order to get an already completed
algorithm however
here the characters have not lived
through that moment and others putting
the pieces in place to let the algorithm
be collected
so that sator can assemble it in order
for them to steal it
yes i was as lost as you are now if we
look at the neil we meet at this point
he saves the protagonist's life meets
him in india and then the two go through
the airport scene
highway chase and then invert in order
to go back to this point in time
so that they can stop the algorithm from
being dumped now neil is aware of his
mission from the off whereas the
protagonist that we follow is not
he is currently working for the cia and
was tipped off that there would be an
attack at the opera house which would
allow him and his team to slip in
and make contact with a ukrainian high
official known as the well-dressed man
before the real swat team even arrive
both the protagonists forces
and one half of sators wait in a van for
them to show up
so that the former team can slip in and
meet this contact in order to get a
special package
the cia are already being duplicitous
here and they plan to work with saitor's
men but double-cross them in order to
get the well-dressed man
so that they can gain intel from him
they want to swap him out with their
decoy
so that they have a mole in sators
operation and can also learn
exactly what the hell is going on now
they are sitting waiting for the events
to kick off in order to infiltrate the
location
under the guise of a swat team this is
why we see them wait until a specific
group arrives
so that they can choose the exact badges
to use in order to infiltrate undetected
but how did they know this would happen
especially as the event hadn't even
taken place yet
from the protagonist's point of view
well this is because the cia was tipped
off by the future protagonist
who knew his past self would have to go
through this in order to become him
he of course was a key in supplying the
fake cyanide pills
so that not only his past self would
take one but also so that saito would
get the other in order to use it at the
end
now the reason that i said there were
half of satoru's men with the
protagonist
is because the other half is carrying
out the attacks
this is a temporal pincer in many ways
as one team will set off the events in
order to get the swat team to come in
which will allow the other part of the
team to use the protagonist to get the
algorithm piece
and then they will take it one team is
also tasked with planting explosives in
order to cover their tracks
so no one knows about what they really
got away with now the protagonist waits
until the swat team launches
and they start to pump sleeping gas into
the sealed room this scene in general is
actually based on the moscow theater
hostage crisis
and which gas similar to this was used
however unlike
tenet in real life the gas was poisonous
and it's estimated that deaths were in
the 200s due to complications that were
caused by it
now as this is happening and the
ukrainian swat team are storming the
hepa center of it
the protagonist and the cia team sneak
off and go to his private booth
we see the protagonist dismantle one of
the security guards guns by grabbing the
top of it and yanking it off
and this is something that he would like
to do when fighting himself at the
airport
now another bit of foreshadowing comes
with a password we live in a twilight
world
and this is later used by saito
cementing that he had something to do
with his plot
now it is possible that saito is the one
who tipped off the cia
and that is why they're working with his
men but either way that information
comes from the protagonist who
may have let satan know it in order to
allow his past self to go on the path
that he does
i don't want to go down the rabbit hole
of why sato was actually working for the
protagonist
again but i've made a video on that
which you should definitely check out
if you're still interested now the
protagonist informs the well-dressed man
that this siege is actually a blind to
vanish him
and he gives him the choice to either go
with him or die the well-dressed man
could have easily have remained an
informant and stayed with the ukrainians
but the protagonist telling him this
makes him realize he has to go with the
cia
in order to stay alive thus they leave
the booth
and the protagonist tells him to remain
in a seat so that he can go and get the
algorithm
now it's at this point that he discovers
the explosives laid out by saito's men
and is also caught by a real swat team
member he flips the fake badge of him
and asks who he is
but the protagonist ciat member shows up
and shoots him
and then takes the well-dressed man to
the rally point this is actually a
changing room in the opera itself
but we'll talk about that slightly later
in the video now the protagonist arrives
at the packaging coat racks
and goes to number later in the film an
algorithm piece is named 241 and as we
know it's split into nine parts
241 and 248 do denote separate pieces of
it
but that might just be a reach from here
the protagonist gets the bag and is
confused over the piece
as he doesn't really know what it is he
then goes to the rally point which is
when his cia contact from the van
switches clothes with a well-dressed man
and you may remember him from before as
someone that the protagonist spoke to
the well-dressed man mentions that he
has a way out through a service tunnel
and with one half of the swat team he
takes the algorithm off
and escapes into the sewers now i'm not
sure exactly how
sator's men managed to get hold of the
algorithm but there are two
possibilities
the first one is that we see them
talking about rewinding the clock at the
train yard
and that they're actually carrying out
another temporal pincer to attack the
team in the sewers
thus if this does happen then the
well-dressed man is killed
and the algorithm is taken at this point
however there's also another possibility
that i go with
i think that his team did make it out
and the piece that we later see being
stolen is one in the same
they do look very similar and that makes
the most sense so i do believe that this
is what happened
the protagonist and his team member are
then informed that there's no way to
stop the explosives from detonating
and thus they run back through the opera
house in order to collect them
now a swat team member catches the
protagonist with one and this moment is
slightly confusing
it is possible that he believes the
protagonist is planting it
and then thinks that he's the one behind
the attack however
it could also be one of sator's men in
disguise and this is why we hear the
line you don't have to kill them
either way it all comes to the same
conclusion but yeah a couple of
possibilities here
including the russians potentially even
trying to cover up that they've just
gassed lots of people
i might even be wrong about saito's men
planting the explosives
and this would be more in line with the
moscow theater crisis in which there was
a cover-up by the russians
because yeah it looked bad that they
basically killed the hostages that they
were trying to save
whoever he is though he has a gun to the
character's head but an inverted bullet
flies backwards through him and goes
into neil's gun
if you can't get your head around this
then do understand that we see this in
full motion later in the movie
when the protagonist is firing a gun at
the wall off topic but this wall
actually comes from stahls 12
which is why the bullet and so on go
backwards from it
big shout outs for hd gaming for
recognizing that now neil runs off and
with his buddy the protagonist throws
the explosives
and returns to saito's team's van
however
they know that they've been double
crossed and thus they double cross the
cia and take them to the train yard
to find out where the real well-dressed
man and algorithm are
we can see trains moving in different
directions and this actually subtly
foreshadows the direction that time will
be going in the movie
they then start to torture the
protagonist for information and at one
point
even pull his teeth out his cyanide pill
is removed
but he manages to get one from his ally
who kept a hold of theirs
believing that he's dead saito's men
leave him at the train yard
and he's then picked up by the forces of
tennit they give him time to rest
and though never explicitly stated i
think that tenet distributed numerous
cyanide pills throughout the cia
which actually put people in a coma over
the years
several were supposed to take them as
part of tenant testing who was worthy of
joining their ranks
but only the protagonist ever went
through with it he's given the keyword
tenant and then dropped off at a
windmill out the way
and we like to see a future version of
the protagonist on the same boat passing
this location
so it's clear that he was purposely
placed here out the way in order to stop
himself from interacting with his future
version
anyway that's pretty much the opening of
the movie i know it's difficult to
understand
especially with a dialogue but hopefully
this helped out now
i'm really conscious that you might need
an explanation video to explain this
video
so hopefully if i've missed something
out or something's unclear
people in the comments have now given us
the answers that we crave so much
i think i did an alright job though but
if you if you want to drop something
below that's totally fine
as there's so many different ways that
you can really take this opening
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of january
in which we're giving away three copies
of the hobbit and lord of the rings 4k
box sets to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the movie
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the theory that
cat is the true future protagonist which
will be linked on screen right now
we go over all the evidence to support
it and why just make so much sense after
several watches
so definitely check it out after this
anyway thank you for sitting through to
the start of this video
i've been ball you being the best and
i'll see you next time take care
peace